nostradamus
strikes
again
yesterday the fbi raided donald trump's
home
at mar-a-lago and in this case i truly
hate to say
i told you so
this timing was even weirder than
you know about this because i've i've
suggested things like this might happen
before but the timing was really really
weird because i told you so or more
specifically i told my friend ali stucky
so about one hour before the raid took
place
ali and i were here and ali was in
nashville we were filming some stuff we
were discussing whether or not we would
bet on trump winning re-election in 2024
and i said look i love the guy i voted
for him twice if he were the nominee in
2024 i would happily vote for him a
third time
i even think most people would vote for
him especially after this terrible
administration we've got right now but
i said i would not bet
on trump winning in 2024 because there's
just one reason
i am not sure that the powers that be
will let him win talking about the fbi
the doj the deep state the crooks who
changed all the election rules last time
the big tech cartel the whole blob i'm
not just talking about biden or the
house democrats i'm talking about the
whole
array of established interests i just
don't know that they will let trump win
whatever the voters want
okay when we're talking about the
liberal establishment we're talking
about groups that have a lot of power
the groups that already use that power
to rig the election in 2020 i don't see
any reason that they wouldn't do it
again
now that they are even more fully
ensconced in power
it's just something about trump more so
than other republicans they just hate
this guy they hate the way that he
shakes things up and i just didn't know
if they're gonna let him do it within an
hour of that conversation with ali
the fbi raided president trump's home
mar-a-lago reportedly looking for
classified documents that he had there
that was the that was the presumptive
basis for the raid
the fbi which never raided hillary
clinton for the 30 000 emails containing
classified info that she had on a server
at her home the fbi which has yet to
raid hunter biden's home despite video
evidence of him committing national
security compromising crimes that same
fbi is now focusing all of its attention
on raiding the home of joe biden's most
prominent and most popular political
opponent
not just a former president don't forget
the guy who is currently leading
in the polls by a long shot for the
republican nomination in 2024 the
biggest political threat to joe biden
now ironically the raid has a
paradoxical effect on the one hand it
proves my point
it shows that the establishment will do
absolutely anything to stop trump in
2024. on the other hand
it makes trump's admirers myself
included
even more inclined than perhaps we
already were to support him again
where does that leave us does that leave
us with
trump 2024
desantis 2024 cruz 2024
biden 2024
no
it leaves us with a banana republic in
2022 and no end in sight to the
corruption i'm michael knowles that's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
my favorite comment yesterday is from
michael owen who says this must have
been a good episode youtube blocked me
from watching it
many such cases many such stories seems
whenever i've got that really good spicy
stuff you know that that spicy
commentary that kind of cuts past just
the left right republican democrats that
talks about kind of systemic
issues
sometimes then i don't know it just gets
blocked it's weird it's weird how that
works when you want to protect yourself
from these established powers when you
want to protect your assets especially
if the fbi could illegitimately raid
your house you really got to check out
alto ira right now go to alto ira.com
michael cryptocurrency may represent the
money of the future especially now that
the u.s dollar is basically not worth
the paper that it's printed on
crypto is one of the most exciting
investment opportunities to come around
for a long time but what about taxes did
you know that you can trade bitcoin
ethereum and over 80 other
cryptocurrencies in a tax advantaged ira
with alto crypto ira you can avoid or
defer the taxes when trading crypto like
bitcoin alto offers alternative
investment opportunities like private
companies crypto funds real estate
venture capital and more no commissions
no paperwork you create an account in as
little as 10 minutes you can invest with
as little as 10
through alto's integration with coinbase
you get secure trading 24 7 150 plus
available coins on their interface
including bitcoin ethereum and cardano
alto offers industry-leading security
the advanced encryption standard for
wallets and private keys and alternative
investment opportunities through some of
the world's most recognized platforms
and fund partners plus there are
multiple ways to fund your account you
can make a cash contribution transfer
from an existing ira roll over an old
401k open an alto crypto ira with as
little as 10 bucks go to altoira dot com
slash michael that's a l t o i r a dot
com slash michael start investing in
cryptocurrency today alto ira.com
michael
absolutely
crazy news story
even though i predicted it
even though i said this sort of thing is
going to happen because trump is just
different and they hate trump in a
special way and you're going to see all
sorts of political stops you know
absolutely no holes barred you're going
to see
illegal actions you already have seen
illegal actions by these same groups by
the fbi by the doj
even though i predicted it it doesn't
make it less
offensive and less shocking that we're
now
descended into such banana republic
level nonsense that you've got the
president sicking the federal government
seeking federal law enforcement on his
main political opponent
if this happened in in brazil
forget if this happened in syria if this
happened in iraq
we would we would say this is
illegitimate this is ridiculous
what a sham democracy they've got in
these sorts of places and now we're
seeing it happen in our own country
pathetic what was this about
according to the new york times
according to the the paper of record of
the liberal establishment the raid was
focused on material that trump had
brought with him to mar-a-lago his
private club in residence after he left
the white house
those boxes contained many pages of
classified documents
oh he had classified documents in places
he shouldn't have had them like hillary
like hillary clinton on her server 30
000 emails with classified material and
she just wiped it clean before before
federal law enforcement could find it
not that not that federal law
enforcement was ever really going to
look
like kind of like that
by the way the president has the right
to declassify whatever he wants
so
i'm not saying it's it's right for trump
to take classified material if that's
even what he did
but
while he was president he could have
declassified that material you're
telling me the fbi is going to raid the
home of a former president and
even even more shocking future
presidential candidate likely future
presidential candidate over the
presidential records act
that's it
i don't think so
new york times goes on trump also faces
a criminal investigation from the
justice department over alleged efforts
to overturn the 2020 election results
there we go okay now we're getting a
little more real
they're upset because donald trump
pointed out that the election was rigged
he just pointed it out they changed all
the election rules right before the
election and they made it much more
vulnerable to fraud even by the standard
of barack obama and in some cases they
violated the state constitutions
in in different states
yeah it was rigged duh
duh hello and everyone knows that the
libs even admitted that they rigged the
thing there was a whole big magazine
article afterward how we rigged the
election such that it was more
advantageous for democrats and and
disadvantages to republicans
and then when you say
write back to them what they just told
you they say you're not allowed to say
that that's a crazy conspiracy theory
believe us don't believe your own lying
eyes
finally new york times says
prosecutors have also reportedly asked
about trump's alleged attempt to
pressure vice president mike pence to
overturn the results of the election so
now
trump isn't even allowed to publicly say
that he wants the vice president to
invoke a kind of measure that we saw
not that is frequently invoked in
american history but which is not
unprecedented to object to the
certification of certain slates of
electors in the election we did see this
in the 1870s and and there was a process
that came out of that which is a process
that senator cruz and representative
paul gosar suggested that we have a kind
of presidential election commission
afterward to analyze the many
irregularities that took place in 2020
when they changed all the rules in some
cases illegally
so all that what that now that's the
so what's the basis for the rate it's
that
or it's the the fact that he may have
had some documents at his home like
hillary clinton did or the fact that
he complained about the election what is
it
what is it
as far as i can tell there are three
options here for what this raid is about
there are only three up
the
most shallow option is that this was
just routine fbi work this is just
routine doj nothing to do with biden
nothing to do with stopping trump from
running in 2024 or none of that right
i think we can dismiss that out of hand
you don't raid the president's home over
the stupid presidential records act
second option here the this is an
attempt to kill trump's candidacy in
2024 in the cradle this is an attempt to
wield federal law enforcement to stop
trump from running in 2024 because the
democrats think that he would beat them
and they just simply will not allow him
to be president again and they can't
beat him at the ballot box in a fair and
square election so they're going to just
raid his home and try to stop him from
running in 2024. or
there's a third possibility this is the
4d chess possibility
that actually this was an attempt to
ensure
a trump
candidacy in 2024
that by raiding the home by targeting
trump he becomes a martyr whatever
support other candidates were getting in
the republican party now that goes right
back to trump
these republicans say we got to double
down if they're going to come after him
he's got to be our nominee and that in a
kind of 4d chess way that's what the
democrats want because they feel that
they can beat him in 2024. those are the
three options
which do i think is most likely number
two
i think this
i don't think that the democrats play 4d
chess all that well sometimes they do
sometimes sometimes people in politics
play 4d chess but
when you're looking at a situation
especially where there's so many
variables where things can spiral out of
control usually the simpler answer
is correct
in this case the idea that it was just
routine fbi work i think is absurd and
not backed up by precedent the idea that
it was 4d chess and they really secretly
want to support trump or what i don't
really buy that i think the establish i
think i think that my thesis from the
very beginning was correct and i think
it's being proven more correct every day
the libs simply will not tolerate
a donald trump
second term
and they will do everything they can
even if it
throws the the nation into a kind of
banana republic status even if it
violates the law even if it violates all
of our political norms they will do
anything it takes they will use any
means necessary to stop trump 2024.
speaking of killing things
do you have a will right now go to
epicwell.com use code knowles the left's
persistent and loud attack on the truth
is aimed directly at your children you
see in the public school system you see
it in the mainstream kids entertainment
you see it on social media platforms
seemingly all of our nation's cultural
institutions have been infiltrated by
the left's
not-so-secret agenda as they say to
indoctrinate your kids with
anti-religious anti-american ideologies
they prey on the vulnerability
and malleability of your kids brains and
they seek to warp your kids
understanding of themselves and their
environment there are a lot of ways you
can protect your kids from these not so
secret agendas you can homeschool you
get them involved in your church
but one of the easiest and simplest ways
to protect your kids is to take five
minutes tonight and write a will with
epic will a will gives you the power to
say who will raise your kids should
something god forbid happen to you and
your spouse it can in certain cases be
the only legal defense standing between
your kids and the persistent power grabs
from the left epic will is an online
will platform costs less than your next
trip to target they can set you up with
a will in as little as five minutes
starts at just a hundred nineteen
dollars plus you can save ten percent
when you go to epicwheel.com use code
knowles take five minutes tonight write
a will ensuring that your kids will be
raised the way that you would intend in
the event that something happens to you
go to epicwell.com use code knowles
today
new york times is saying the quiet part
out loud on the trump raid breathlessly
they report right as the raid is
happening headline quote if trump broke
a law on the removal of official records
would he be barred from future office
they asked so giddily you can you can
just picture the smile on this reporters
charlie savage on his face his hands oh
goody goody boy are we gonna finally get
rid of trump specifically he writes the
law in question section 2071 of title 18
of the u.s code makes it a crime if
someone who has custody of government
documents
or records quote willfully and
unlawfully conceals removes mutilates
obliterates false visor destroys them if
convicted
defendants can be fined or sentenced to
prison for up to three years in addition
the statute says if they're currently in
federal office they shall forfeit that
office and they shall be disqualified
from holding any office
under the united states
now eugene wallock over at the wallock
conspiracy has a good article on why no
even if trump were prosecuted for this
even if he were convicted for this that
wouldn't bar him from running for
president again
so worth reading but the libs are
clearly trying to push this idea
the times writes on its face then if mr
trump were to be charged and convicted
of removing concealing or destroying
government records under that law he
would seem to be ineligible to become
president again the the only caveat they
have here is there was reason for
caution however the law briefly received
a close look in 2015 after it came to
light that hillary clinton then widely
anticipated to be the 2016 democrat
presidential nominee had used a private
email server to conduct government
business while secretary of state
uh but you know we're going to get rid
of that idea
so you you can see
the way that the libs are thinking
they're thinking
this is a really good way to get rid of
trump oh yeah let's use this strange
provision of the u.s code and this
ridiculous rule about
presidential record keeping let's say
that that is a way to stop the most
popular republican from becoming the
nominee in 2024. yeah that'll do it oh
shoot
ah darn we already we already argued
against this position when they were
going to use it against hillary clinton
when hillary clinton did at least the
very same thing trump did if not much
worse because we're talking about 30 000
emails on an unsecured server that's
very easily hackable that's that almost
certainly was hacked by foreign
governments
hmm uh darn okay well let's just let's
just float it out there anyway but darn
we probably can't use it because we made
the opposite argument last time when
hillary clinton did the same thing and
didn't get raided by the fbi
when in in almost the same circumstances
when she was the presumptive democrat
nominee as trump is the presumptive
republican nominee this time the only
difference is hillary was never
president
hillary had far less of a right to use
these sorts of classified materials than
the president had because she was only a
secretary of state
and and first lady former first lady
really really
dubious stuff
really banana republic kind of stuff
that you see in the new york times and
obviously you're seeing from the fbi and
the whole episode is weird
not just because of what happened not
just because i predicted it pretty much
as it was happening or just an hour or
so before it actually happened
really weird because
trump seems to have predicted it
so i got to give a hat tip here to my uh
my twitter friend you demonia
the uh
one of the great pseudonymous twitter
accounts if you're not following him you
should referring to the ancient greek
idea of happiness and human flourishing
he pointed out that the truth social
instagram account
had made a series of posts
going back back into july for for
several weeks now
in which the post was just a picture of
trump from the back
clearly with heavy stage lights on him
clearly looking at a crowd wearing the
maga hat it says 45 right there on the
maga hat
and just right on his back it says 8
8
20 22.
so all it is is trump talking to a live
crowd with the presidential hat on
with the date
of the fbi raid
it says join the club to stand up to the
tyranny of big tech
truth social is open then some some of
the posts would just say the date and it
cycled through i think he did four posts
like this at least
another strange thing about the date
august 8th 2022 the date of this raid
is the date that richard nixon resigned
richard nixon whose presidency i think
is one of the most misrepresented in
american history there are a lot of
there are a lot of parallels to the
trump administration but not in the way
that the libs
i i think want to present it the libs
want to say richard nixon was a crook he
was terrible he was the most corrupt
president ever and just like trump trump
is corrupt and awful and he should have
resigned office too and they tried to
they tried to impeach
richard nixon they did impeach donald
trump
uh twice it didn't work
and so those are the perils they want to
see quite the opposite richard nixon
i think was actually one of the least
corrupt presidents in modern times not
saying the guy was perfect the guy had a
lot of problems
but what happened richard nixon
got up to some campaign shenanigans that
he wasn't even aware of
the democrats have gotten up to much
worse campaign shenanigans in pretty
much every presidential campaign
before richard nixon and after richard
nixon in modern times
and
what happened the deep state undermined
the nixon administration he got him
booted out and the swiss republicans
went along with it
very similar parallels here because
richard nixon was threatening certain
entrenched interests
that's what happened
so 8 22. do you think that the deep
state this time was sending a message
with that date possibly what was trump
planning to do on that date was he
planning to announce
for for 2024
and then the fbi raid happens and so he
doesn't announce i'm not sure it seems a
little early for him to announce a
presidential campaign a lot of people
are encouraging him to wait to announce
until after the midterm elections
all various i don't have an explanation
for that i'm just pointing out strange
coincidences here
now
the number two candidate for the
presidential nomination in 2024 happens
to be the governor of florida the state
that was invaded by the fbi to raid
donald trump's house ron desantis has
come out very strongly against the raid
he said quote the rate of mar-a-lago
is another escalation in the
weaponization of federal agencies
against the regime's political opponents
while people like hunter biden get
treated with kid gloves now the regime
is getting another 87 000 irs agents to
wield against its adversaries banana
republic i agree with every single word
of that the desantis administration says
they did not have any advance warning of
this fbi raid
and
so he's coming out very strongly to
defend trump notice though he doesn't
defend trump by name here
he doesn't you even use the phrase
mar-a-lago he actually just abbreviates
it m-a-l maybe that's because of the
character limits on twitter and he
tweeted it out from his personal twitter
account
so he didn't tweet it out from the
governor's account which to me implies
that there won't be any legal action
taken to
to try to punish the fbi for this raid
which i think was obviously illegitimate
so he's saying i'm with you guys this is
awful this is terrible
but
i'm gonna i'm gonna do this for my
personal account because obviously
desantis and trump are big political
rivals right now if trump runs in 2024
the odds that desantis becomes the
nominee are very low if trump does not
run in 2024 right now desantis is the
leading candidate things can change it's
very early in the cycle
in every other presidential cycle the
candidates who were leading at this time
did not end up becoming the nominee but
it's possible he's got a very strong
position he's done a great job as
governor of florida
so desantis is in this impossible
position he doesn't want to help out his
political rival but he shares a lot of
the same base as donald trump and the
fbi raid was just so obviously corrupt
and illegitimate that he's got to come
out against it because he's he's the
tough conservative fighter candidate so
he's trying to balance all these
competing interests
then on the other hand you got the court
jesters you got the squishes who love
this the people who have hated trump
from the beginning they absolutely love
this even unfortunately the court jester
group even includes people
who have worked for trump
that this woman who i had never heard of
until it was announced she's going to
come on to the view as she's going to be
the new fake republican on the view her
name is alyssa
farah griffin and she worked for trump
and then she totally squished out and
condemned trump and wind and cried and
sucked up to the liberal establishment
she came out after this ridiculous raid
this this absolute banana republic
lawlessness from biden she tweets out
totally what you would expect she says
the inflammatory rhetoric coming from
some on the right this evening is
frightening it's from the right not that
the the biden administration is
weaponizing the fbi to invade his for
his
predecessor and current political rivals
home that's not what's frightening no
not that the biden administration just
hired 87 000 irs agents to to go after
you no no that's not what's frightening
what's frightening is the rhetoric
from people on the right
people like michael knowles and the
daily wire that's so frightening this
and probably
she's referring to trump and ron
desantis and
a lot of the rest of the people on the
right she says
elected officials especially need to
tone down the rhetoric and let the facts
play out in this environment words
matter so much
no you know what i think matters more
power
i don't think the words matter i don't
think that the libs made a good argument
with words as to why they need to
raid the homes of their political rivals
i think they just had the power to do it
and they wielded that power
and and now the role of conservatives
is to
resist that and to hopefully win and get
some power back for ourselves and the
role of court jester conservatives like
alyssa griffin alyssa who's whose job it
is to just go out there and do a little
dance for the liberal establishment and
pretend to be opposition and then at the
crucial moments fall back and concede
the point
to to lose with dignity even though
these people have absolutely no dignity
whatsoever that's their job
they're worse than the libs the libs at
least i know where i stand the libs i
know are going to raid my home and wield
political power as best they can and try
to undermine my my elected officials and
i i know what i'm getting with the libs
these people though
they're just absolute rats they're just
rats they're just they have no loyalty
to anybody other than trying to get a
few crumbs from the large yes of the
liberal table that's what they want it's
pathetic it's disgusting very very
shameful
if you have not heard already the daily
wire is now the sixth largest podcast
publisher
in the country we are ahead of the walt
disney company add to that the launch of
daily wire plus the signing of jordan
peterson the documentaries the movies
the kids content things are getting busy
around here to keep up we are actively
hiring for our marketing team in
nashville we're looking for social media
coordinators email marketers art
directors everything in between
if you have experience in marketing we
want to hear from you head on over to
dailywire.com careers check out our
current openings and apply dailywire.com
careers
speaking of political rhetoric heated up
rhetoric
the mayor of new york eric adams
is really ratcheting up the rhetoric
against the illegal aliens who are
showing up in his sanctuary city
it's a little strange right he's got a
sanctuary city he and the rest of the
democrat new yorkers talk a great game
about how happy they are they love
getting all of those illegal immigrants
the illegal immigration is our strength
bring on the diversity it's not a lot of
diversity they're all coming from the
same three countries illegally but no
that's wonderful we need to flood the
country with all these people
just not in my city
just just not in my backyard
eric adams says this is horrific
when you think about what governor
abbott in texas is doing
unimaginable it's unimaginable what the
governor of texas has done
when you think about this country
a country that's always been open to
those who are fleeing persecution
what is the governor of texas doing
he's not turning the people away
he's not turning the countless illegal
aliens showing up across the border away
the 2 million plus that we're getting
now every year
he's actually welcoming them he's giving
them a free bus ticket
he's giving them stuff and he's saying
hey
look we we're not a sanctuary state we
don't we still believe in the laws of
the united states passed by the people's
representatives but there are places in
america that don't care at all about the
laws passed by the american people's
representatives and they they they want
all these illegal immigrants to come so
hey we're gonna give you a free ticket
and pay for it give you a ticket send
you up to that sanctuary city new york
eric adams says this is horrific
why is it horrific
governor abbott is giving you exactly
what you want exactly what you say that
you want but you don't really want it
you want illegal aliens
for the red states you don't want the
illegal aliens for your blue city huh
it's weird
why is that
why is it that illegal aliens are our
strength they're a great benefit net
contributors to the american economy and
society in red states
but their arrival in new york is
horrific and unimaginable
it doesn't make oh oh unless it is the
case that there are
two separate tiers here
two separate standards two separate
systems
and
the uh
the republicans it's really good when
the illegal aliens shows up to the
republican states because that weakens
those states and gives democrats more
power and it's really bad when they show
up to the democrat states because
actually illegal immigration is a net
negative for everybody
and the democrats don't want them to
show up to their backyard because then
they're going to have to expend
resources they're going to see increases
in crime they're going to see increases
in welfare dependency they're going to
see strains on their resources all the
stuff that the republicans had to deal
with which the democrats celebrated
maybe that's what it is maybe it's not
in my backyard it was even more
ridiculous when you tuned in to cnn
which i know you did not i did not
either but i saw this clip going around
murad
awadda
murad awada is an immigration activist
who appears on cnn
and he is furious he is absolutely
furious
that
the governor of texas is bussing the
migrants on texan's own dime to the
sanctuary cities
the city is estimating that some 4 000
asylum seekers have arrived in the city
gone into new york's shelter system
since late may do you agree with the
mayor that these migrants are being
forced to
new york asylum seekers have really um
already made a dangerous truck some over
3 000 miles on foot to get to the
southern border and then are being bust
almost 2 000 miles to new york city
i think that the
bigger piece here is ensuring that we
see the humanity in people
folks who are seeking asylum at our
southern border are fleeing violence
they're fleeing persecution impacts of
climate change no one leaves their home
because they feel safe so it's really
important that this country a country of
immigrants uh continues uh to welcome
folks
and abide by humanitarian uh you know
values it's really important that we
welcome folks just not here
it's just really awful what they're
doing in texas sending these immigrants
to new york if you if you just listen to
that clip you don't see what's on the
wall directly behind him
uh to his left right behind him
on the right of the screen you see
a sign that says no raids
no wall
new york is for all
and then on the left of the screen you
see no hate no fear immigrants are
welcome here and both signs say new york
city new york city right underneath
except for these immigrants they got to
stay in texas it's because it's so
important to welcome them in texas
and not in new york is for all except
for the immigrants that are being bussed
from texas we don't please keep them in
texas
therefore no hate
no wall
send them back to texas
all of them send all of them back
it's just total nimby it's just total
not in my backyard and it gives away the
whole game now as i said earlier the
libs are not really interested in having
these reasoned debates i think we're
kind of past that i think i think when
the federal government sits its private
police on the political opponents and
raids their homes i think we're kind of
past the polite civil dialogue part of
politics so it's it's not as though
you're going to be able to make this
argument say see your hypocrites and the
democrats will say bye golly you're
right okay i've got to change my
policies now they don't care it's just
it is just pure
club our opponents over the head kind of
bare-knuckle personal interest politics
that we're seeing from the left right
now okay
but it is worth pointing out
one for the republicans to see what
we're really dealing with and and two
most importantly for the centrists and
the squishes
and the people who just don't think very
much about politics because they've got
other things going on and they pay
attention to their families and they got
their job and their heads and their
noses aren't in the political reports
and political philosophy all the time as
is often the case for those those people
who listen to this show who are more
high information voters all right it's
important for the the lower information
voters to see what's really going on
here oh the illegal immigration thing
that the democrats push it's not about
compassion it's not about helping people
it's not about our traditions or our
strength or who we are it's just about
power
oh the hatred against donald trump and
it's not about trump's unique threat to
america and the unique crimes that he's
it's just it's just that he was
threatening the established order
and so there it's just about power
okay that's what it is
the reason they go after trump in
particular to kind of circle back to
this
is
a lot of people think that trump won the
election
in spite of his policies because of his
rhetoric
because he talked really mean and funny
and he had these big rallies there is
really so busy and that's why he won the
election not because of his policies
obviously he's funny he's a captivating
figure he's a celebrity for 40 years so
that plays some role in in his campaign
but i actually think it was kind of the
opposite the people that i talk to will
say you know i really love trump's
policies i really love his approach i
just wish he would shut up sometimes i
just wish he would tone it down on
twitter sometimes
that's that's much more what i heard
than the opposite
i
don't know that i met anybody
any actual person i know this phenomenon
was described on cnn and in the new york
times and even on some some squish
platforms on the right
i know that what they would say is you
know the reason people vote for trump
they actually they hate his policies
they don't care about his policies they
just love when he talks about mika
brzezinski's face yeah that's what it's
all about but when you talk to actual
trump voters
i've spoken to a lot of them i am a
trump voter myself
that's not what they said at least seven
times out of ten what they said is yeah
he's gotta cool it he's gotta lay off
that twitter man a little bit you know
he's gotta pick his battles a little
more but man i love his policy on trade
you know i just i really love his
approach to foreign trade and his
approach to china which is america first
i really love his approach to
immigration
what did they chant at the rallies build
the wall build the wall
trump offered different policies than
the other candidates did
there were what 16 17 candidates on that
stage in 2016. trump offered different
policies
pretty much all the other candidates
were pro free trade all the time open up
global markets no thought at all to
american manufacturing or american
industry trump pretty much alone said
nah we need to bring industry back here
we need to bring manufacturing back here
we need to institute tariffs we need to
get really tough on trade imbalances and
all the other republicans pulled their
hair out over that he said what are you
talking about for the last 10 years our
party line has been free trade even
though actually the republican party was
founded on tariffs was founded on
protectionism even though abraham
lincoln said give me a tariff i'll give
you the strongest country in the world
even though actually the issue of trade
and tariffs and protectionism is a
little more complicated than the liberal
establishment let's on trump offered a
different
option
how about on immigration
some republicans made some intimations
that they would get tough on immigration
none of them spoke as bluntly as trump
and none of them proposed as radical a
proposal as donald trump did which is
build a big beautiful wall and deport
all the illegals
unfortunately he didn't end up
fulfilling a lot of that and in many
ways he was hampered by the deep state
even if he had wanted to do such a thing
but he was offering a different approach
to immigration on policy
not just on rhetoric
and i think that is why
the powers that be and i'm not just
talking about biden i'm talking about
the big corporations and i'm talking
about
the entrenched ideological interests in
the universities in our educational
system i'm talking about the big tech
cartel
i'm talking about
the chamber of commerce i'm talking
about all of these groups
they
oppose trump
because he was offering a different set
of policies from from what is called the
uniparty
isn't it kind of weird the democrats win
the republicans win no matter who wins
the same sorts of problems get worse
when you think of especially on the
social issues the kind of crazy sexual
decadence that we're at now where we're
transiting little kids
no matter who wins the democrats when
the republicans win
and it always just kind of on
immigration the democrats when the
republicans win we get more and more and
more immigration legal illegal all the
same
republicans when democrats win we
outsource more and more jobs we lose
more and more industry
we change our economy more and more it's
just it's
that's weird that's weird that that
happens and then you get this wrecking
ball who shows up named donald trump
and you can you can totally understand
how powerful entrenched interests would
say nope not gonna let that happen we
might let a bush win every now and again
we ain't letting that guy win not again
uh-uh
which
paradoxically has the effect of getting
people to support him more
i i don't make
primary endorsements
i just don't think that's my position
here on the show rush limbaugh didn't
make primary endorsements i don't make
primary endorsements i think the my job
here on the show is to present to you
the facts as i see them laid out in the
field let people sort of make up their
own mind
however i will tell you this
i i love the gop field right now i love
trump i think desantis is the best
governor certainly right now maybe of my
lifetime and you know i'm a huge
supporter of senator cruz and there are
other candidates in in the potential gop
field that
that i like and could support
the raid on mar-a-lago
makes me more inclined to support trump
even though the raid on mar-a-lago tells
me he's less likely to win the general
paradoxically it makes me more inclined
to support him
in a primary because i think
no no you guys don't get away with this
you don't get to do this
okay
i think that's true of a lot of
republicans i took a very scientific
twitter poll last night i said
does this make you more or less likely
to support trump two-thirds of people
said much more likely
of course
now again maybe 4d chess that's what the
democrats want i don't know
all i know is
we are in uncharted
territory right now we're an uncharted
territory in a whole lot of ways there's
a story out of california from the state
senator scott weiner
who is one of the biggest degenerates in
american politics i mean this guy is the
poster child of american political
degeneracy this guy came to uh
prominence a couple of years ago because
he sponsored a bill called sb 145
which was a bill to weaken punishments
for pederasts
for grown men
who have sex with little boys
it would weaken
the punishments or it would give judges
more discretion to weaken the
punishments and i looked at that bill
when someone told me about that bill i
said that sounds like a crazy right-wing
conspiracy theory then i looked it up
and it was true
and they made all sorts of arguments
you'll see politifact snopes all these
groups they make all these sorts of
fact-check arguments they say no
actually the purpose of this bill was to
to uh create equality for homosexuals
and heterosexuals in the sentencing of
statutory rape and it's all it's
actually about equality what's the
practical effect of the bill this guy
actually came up proposed a bill he said
we need to
go a little lighter on the pederasts
that's what it actually did you can't
fact-check me on that because
that is the fact
that 100 true
not in any way false not in any way
misleading that's just what the bill did
and that this guy scott weiner
nature is but art unknown to the chance
direction which that can't not see what
a name scott weiner that he makes that
his bill
just a couple of days ago
scott weiner furthered his degenerate
profile by describing
all of the sex parties that go on among
his friends his constituency and how
that's going to keep happening whether
you get monkey pox or not he says
if people want to have sex they're going
to have sex
i know people who normally go to sex
parties who will not now you know maybe
for a little bit uh people who will make
their own decisions about their own risk
levels he was talking about the san
francisco
gay fetish festival that just occurred
that occurred even though there's a
gay orgy disease called monkey pox going
around he said i know someone who was
working the door at one of the sex
parties the weekend of this festival and
the attendance was down by 50 percent
and i've heard that about some other sex
parties as well so
my takeaway here
these parties should not exist they
should be shut down this festival should
be shut down especially when there's a
gay orgy box going around but my other
takeaway is
what level of depravity is our country
sunk to that a sitting state senator can
just speak casually about his friends
just going to orgies and sex parties oh
yes look i've got some friends i've got
a friend who works at the sex parties
this is so this
should be
so shameful
that any man
who like this who even knows people who
go to these parties would never admit it
in public or any man who does admit this
kind of deviancy and degeneracy would
never show his face in public this guy
should be on the absolute fringes of
society he should be able to say these
things
at the most in little dark alleys next
to cd movie theaters instead he's doing
it from the halls of the state capitol
in california
that is a major change this sort of
thing would have been unthinkable
ten years ago five years ago
things
are accelerating quickly
speaking of
a really really degenerate culture
there is a
horrifying story that just came out of
georgia
the story is that two homosexual men
have been charged with using their
adopted children to record child
pornography
these guys are william and zachary
zulock
they have the same name i assume they're
not brothers so i don't know what one of
the other guy one guy took the other
guy's name i guess
they adopted two kids and then they used
the kids to make child pornography
not the first time we've heard this
story
this story even though gay marriage has
not existed as a concept for more than
seven years really and not at the
national level even though gay adoption
is
still illegal in a whole lot of places
and it's a very novel concept we keep
hearing these stories it's kind of weird
there's another story they tell you
these stories they don't happen it's one
in a bazillion well i don't know there's
another story came around from
queensland
uh the story
oh gosh this is awful the headline
is in yahoo news
he was a child star but for all the
wrong reasons he made his debut at just
22 months old not for a toy store
advertisement or even a family-friendly
pg film this was for hardcore global
pornographic syndication he was filmed
being sexually abused by his adoptive
parents quote unquote and at least eight
other pedophiles in australia france
germany and the united states
uh his horrific introduction to the
insidious world of pedophilia dated back
to 2005 when his russian mother sold him
for eight thousand dollars to a member
of boy lovers a sophisticated global
network of men whose sexual preference
for boys aged between six
and uh eight years old
uh the boy was adopted quote unquote by
american mark j newton who lived in
brisbane and his australian boyfriend
peter trong
now what's really crazy about this story
is that
there had previously been a puff piece
about this couple a puff piece about how
wonderful it was that they adopted this
boy because back this is 2013 now the
idea of gay adoption was really pretty
much unthinkable at that point and so
there was this big puff piece being
pushed by the liberal media to say look
they've overcome so many obstacles legal
and social to finally have their
fulfillment to
to adopt their child and form this
family despite the constraints of nature
and society that that article is even
referenced in this
in this
uh
article on their crimes
look how it turned out look how it
turned out didn't turn out great
the conclusion from this and i know a
lot of squishes aren't going to want to
say it
homosexual adoption is a terrible idea
it's a terrible idea and it's i think
just simply unsupportable you can't it's
it's just unacceptable for not because
every kid who's adopted by homosexuals
is going to be abused i don't think
that's the case we are seeing a lot of
stories like this it's pretty weird but
that's that's that's not even the base
reason why the base reason why is that
men and women are different
and little i got a little baby at home
right now let me tell you something
little baby reacts very differently to
mama than he does to daddy
even my older son
who's a little bit older than the
newborn reacts very differently to mommy
than he does to daddy
wants different things from mommy
wants because men and women are
different if you believe that men and
women are different i don't see how you
can support homosexual adoption
these men and women have different
things to offer
and when we're talking about adoption
especially when we're talking about
conception especially when we're talking
about an issue like surrogacy or all
these other issues that keep coming up
all we ever talk about now are the
rights of the right of these men
to have a child these men don't have a
right to have a child they can't have a
child together
there's a very
natural scientific basis for why they
can't have a child together and now
they're trying to circumvent that nature
through this radical social engineering
and things don't turn out very well
the only people who we ever talk about
as having rights in these cases are the
are the couples and the couples and
their deep desire to have a child you
don't have a right to have a child
i know it can be hard for people who
especially people who struggle with
infertility or i'm sure it's very hard
for homosexuals too who have a natural
desire to have a child that's a natural
thing to want
but you don't have a right to a child
sweet little elise and i even dealt with
what what seemed like infertility for
quite some time we didn't get our first
kid right away i i can tell you at least
from a couple years experience i know i
know how intense that pain can be but
you do not have a right to a child
you don't
the only person who can be said to have
any rights when we're talking about
procreation when we're talking about
adoption or anything like that the only
person who can be said to have any
rights is the child
a child has a right
to his natural mother and father
conceived in the act
of in the conjugal act between his
parents in a marriage
marriage which is the lifelong bond
between a man and a woman for the sake
of the generation and education of
children that's what it's for
and when you start
tinkering with that things go really
really awry
the the inability of these two men to
have a child
is a kind of
it's a i'm sure it was a pain i mean
these these guys are just absolute
criminals who are are going to rot but
for for other people
it is a pain
pain is not always a bad thing pain is
not an evil thing suffering is not
exactly an evil thing it's kind of just
a fact of life what
is determines good or evil is how you
react to pain how you react to suffering
sometimes pain can be even a good thing
because it tells you that you should
maybe alter your behavior when you put
your hand on the hot stove burner and it
hurts that pain tells you okay i gotta
take my hand away
they're all sorts when you're in a rut
in your life
you feel a kind of pain that tells you
you've got to change certain things all
sorts of personal behaviors when you
feel a kind of pain you're drinking too
much whatever you've got to change that
behavior unfortunately in our
therapeutic culture and in our culture
that establishes the domination of
technology to break off all natural
constraints
all we tend to do is numb the pain
so you're you're in a rut in your life
well just take a bunch of depression
drugs and that's not solving the problem
that's not encouraging
behavior that's more conducive to human
flourishing
it's just kind of numbing the pain a
little bit you don't change a damn thing
that is a much it goes even beyond sex
it goes even beyond questions of
adoption it goes down to a fundamental
issue of how we as human beings
react to one another and to our society
and to technology
we seem to be entering into a brave new
world you know there are two very famous
dystopian novels about written in the
20th century about the future 1984 by
george orwell
and brave new world by aldous huxley
in 1984 says that the tyrannical
government's just going to beat you with
a stick all the time brave new world
says the tyrannical government is going
to apply you with drugs and sex and
promiscuity and all sorts of pleasures
both are going to make you into slaves
we're getting a little bit of both in
our society today it's clearly clearly
accelerating on the personal front on
the cultural front on the destruction of
the family and ultimately on the
political front too
the powers that be are sicking federal
law enforcement on their political
opponents things happen slow and
gradually then they can happen really
really fast we might be in the fast
stage i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.